Everybody please welcome Gary
"Hi Gary"
"Gary!"
Well, uh, my wife and I just recently got married
"Hey!"
She's perfect
She's everything I ever wanted
And you know I'm, I'm having a little tiny bit of trouble bonding with my new stepson Lucas
"Whoa look at that tons of moth worms...
...Good talking to you buddy"
Never really looks me in the eye
Doesn't talk much, except when he yells at me to get out of his room...
... using this weirdo, like, go puppet thing
I get all the sense that he's a ...
That he's Evil incarnate
Yeah
Remind me again how Lucas was conceived
Remember when I told you about that crazy time in my twenties...
...where I joined a, sort of like, a cult
No, I don't think you told me about that
Doomsday Cult believes a child will rise up from hell to rule mankind
And to bring on the end of the world as we know it
I think we found that child
and now, you're his stepdad
There's nothing wrong with Lucas
He's very particular
The child
He did this to me
You told me that was normal, that all kids are dicks
That's true, kids are dicks man, but this is a different level. He's like top of the dick chain, bro
"So creative"
Wow
Hey look out!
This is so great
Dude, bro, you gotta relax man!
How can I relax? We're in corn field
So? What good thing has ever happened in a corn field though?
Well, I don't know!
Field of dreams is pretty cool